you're watching the honeydew with ryan
sickler
[Music]
welcome back to the honeydew with y'all
y'all we're over here at the honeydew
studios highlighting your lowlights
today my guest
is jess danner everybody welcome jess
danner how you doing jess
hi
i'm great it's nice to meet you i'm very
excited as well
um first of all tell everybody where
you're from where are you right now on
lockdown
so i'm from central pennsylvania um just
recently moved to lancaster county
pennsylvania
and
yeah
just bought a house in january chilling
in my house and you said nothing we were
talking before we were recording you
said you're still working what do you do
for a living
so i work for an insurance company um i
do outreach to medicare members
um for appointments and doctors and
stuff like that
so just kind of like insurance calls
well as you know i've reached out to
everybody out there to hear about their
low lights and you hit me with a laundry
list of [ __ ] that started early and
often um so why don't i let you tell
everybody your story please
all right so um
when i was 12
i
was walking i was in middle school i
guess yeah middle school i was walking
home from school and i had a really bad
pain in my back and i was like it's
gotta be like kidney stones or something
went to the emergency room thought it
was kidney stones
turns out i had uh
what's called uterine didelphus it's two
uteruses
um two uteruses
yep okay so i already have questions all
right so
is that
uterus something that was excuse me
undiagnosed all this time or did it did
it grow inside you over a course of time
where it's like holy [ __ ] you grew a
second universe
like how did it go mist
so what it was is the um ingestion when
i was being formed in my mom's uterus uh
it was cell splitage
so the cells that form
your uterus
cervix and all that are similar to the
ones that build your urinary tract
so instead of
another kidney uh those cells formed
into
a uterus
one kidney two uteruses well the
uteruses are gone but
and you said that having one kidney is
rare
well that part isn't so much rare as the
um swapping it for a second uterus is is
pretty rare
so with
the the solitary kidney is very um
common with uterine didalphus or
actually any i don't know if you've ever
heard of like bicoordinate uterus some
women have like a wall i've heard of
nothing you've had
yeah none of that none of this stuff i
mean i think ibs i've heard that
you know what that is yeah i got that
one
so
there could be a lot of
malformations of the
uterus and
any reproductive organ really um but
this cedar and didelphus one is
a little rare and mine was especially
rare because
the septum that goes the whole way down
through
the uteruses this had two cervixes as
well if you know what that is hold on
yeah i listen i do okay i'm sorry to
stop you but i have to tell you this
it's good i do
because segora and i talked about this
my friend shannon went out with a girl
one night and they went back they dated
for a while when they were starting to
get a little hot and heavy he went to go
down her pants and she grabbed him and
she said i'm different and he freaked
out like different like yeah like are
you a guy
or what what is different like what's
going on
and she
had this she had a deviated
like a deviated septum but in her vagina
she had two
i i i know i'm i'm not a doctor i just
want to say this but like two canals two
you know and it sounds like this is what
you're describing
yes so most women with with that and she
might have had uterine didelphis or she
just could have had a bicoordinate
uterus that the septum came the whole
thing she
[Music]
[Laughter]
what was really rare about mine is that
septum instead of coming the whole way
down it grew to the side of my vagina
vaginal wall
and blocked off my left uterus and
cervix and all this time you're a child
you're 12 you're 13.
i imagine you're probably if you haven't
already like we're just going to be real
here like have you had your period at
this point yet
i had gotten my period when i was 12 so
the summer before going back to school
and i had maybe three cycles
three months and it started happening is
everything excruciatingly painful you
said you had the pain in your back so
like is that the beginning of the pain
and it just stays it never like lightens
up it never eases up during during this
part of it
so yeah with especially with the back
pain and like i had cramps and stuff
with my
first period i just thought it was you
know you can get cramps with your period
um
but
i was also like really bloated and like
my belly was really
distended you know sometimes looking
pregnant which
sucks but
um
i just lost my train of thought sorry
what'd you say i was asking you about
just
well also like even as a parent like
your mom i'm guessing maybe didn't go
through this and it's like how helpless
you can feel trying to help your your
child go through all this and figure it
out so you've you're told you have all
of this going on
right
and then what happens do you have to go
for a surgery or procedure like what do
you do for something like that
so when we went to the emergency room
for the kidney stones um they were like
this there's a large mass in your pelvis
and my mom's like
like a tumor right any time you hear
them like what do you mean
a mast yeah
and they're like we need to do uh some
some more testing so i came back to the
hospital and they did
an mri that was like
i think it was like three four hours
long
and that was torture you're in that
[ __ ] tunnel that long no yeah
they kept saying okay we're gonna look
at the pic just hold on one minute okay
we just have to take a few more because
like they
never saw it that's how
rare it is and unknown at least
especially back then how unknown it was
because um
i mean it was like point
zero eight of a million or something my
doctor said it was really outrageous
numbers how rare
my situation was because the septum had
blocked the left side and i was getting
my period and it wasn't going anywhere
so i just had blood sitting
in my pelvis up in your body
and that's what the pressure and the
pain and the
you know so
after that uh they recommended i go to
chop which is children's hospital of
philadelphia or pennsylvania that's a
hell of an acronym for going to get
something taken out of you when you're a
kid shop send her down to chop like okay
where are we going
i'm going to get surgery at chop she's
got three uteruses and six [ __ ] send
her down to chop like what are we
talking about right
yes so and you're a kid are you do you
remember are you scared or are you
a kid are you freaking out or are you
just like oh no you know
are you thinking of are you at that age
are you even thinking about death or
anything like that oh yeah especially
when they were like not sure what the
mass was like i was like i have cancer
like this yeah i'm gonna die especially
if it's in my lady bits you know i mean
like that was usually
from what i knew back then you know
take care of you but um
i was
mostly just following my mom's lead and
my mom i mean i'm so close to there
still she sometimes go to doctor's
appointments with me so
she
i wouldn't be here without her i
would be dead
or i would have offed myself because
she did not stop
uh trying to find the best
doctors the best surgeons
and actually uh she found doc his name
is dr mama
is it really um
yeah at top i don't i think he's in like
new jersey or something now but
he uh he's the one that did my first
surgery and
he did they did uh what's called like
vaginoplasty
uh where they completely like
reconstructed
to make things flow so i can have
periods and hopefully have children
um
you know they got rid of the septum
and my cervix is which was also another
rare thing
there's usually like a little space
between them but mine were like this
like overlapping
so
i had some issues with that
but um
yeah dr mama
sorry
he was like an indian dude which
they're the best surgeons i swear to god
but
he uh
yeah he fixed fix my vagina and to make
it as normal as possible
but then uh he said
that i had endometriosis and he said you
know it's it's all over
your bowel
which i cannot touch so you need to go
to another surgeon oh
so you're coming out of this thing
hoping you're good to go and now it's
done
and now you have more to go
yeah but he has basically reconstructed
your
as you say your lady parts internally as
well so that everything can function
properly
or as it yeah as it's meant to go
yeah his goal was to preserve my
fertility as much as possible if i
wanted to have children in the future
and to
just allow me to have a normal sex life
sometime in my life you know what i mean
and he did an incredible job and it's
funny because when i go to a new
gynecologist and i tell them everything
that's going on you know and then they
take a look i've had doctors say like
wow
it's beautiful he did oh absolute great
work
everything's beautiful i'm like i have a
beautiful vagina thank you mama mia
handcrafted but handcrafted yeah
but yeah um
dr mama was like the beginning of the
saving my life for sure
she did great work and are you at this
age now you're going to get another
surgery coming up and are you playing
sports are you active or is your whole
life in and out of hospitals and
everything else that's another thing
with this was
growing up was a brutal
uh trying to stay in school because like
back in i mean my surgeries were in 05
and 06
and
they didn't have cyber school
all like that
they didn't have homeschooling you know
my mom still had to work to pay my
medical bills um
i might you know my stepdad worked so it
was like no one could stay home and
homeschool me
they told me
i had the solitary kidney they said no
contact sports whatsoever
we can't play soccer
just in case
obviously you can't can't feel like
field hockey like i couldn't i couldn't
do anything i grew up dancing
um so i kind of stuck with i was trying
to still go to classes at my aunt's
dance school
but eventually
i had to quit because
with the first two surgeries i mean it
really wiped me out and i had like no
energy endometriosis is so draining
so i wasn't doing too much and i was
missing school i was doing like uh
partial homebound schooling where i
would do like half days and then
a teacher would come to my house uh so
it was it was very isolating
so you're used to this quarantine [ __ ]
right but you also probably need to be
you have your compromise okay so
you're
you're 14 here and you're now going to
where to get the endometriosis and
endometriosis uh surgery is that what it
is
yeah endometriosis surgery it's actually
the best
surgery treatment is excision because
they can either burn it or cut it
well excising it is cutting it which is
the best way to remove it and uh
dr mama was like you have to go to this
excision specialist in atlanta georgia
he's the best of the best and at the
time he he was um
at the time what do you mean is there
somebody else that came up in the ranks
over the time oh man now there's
specialists all all up and down the east
coast is this
cali
really
oh yeah like the thing with
endometriosis is
a lot of women have it and don't even
know they're just like oh i have bad
periods you know like that's just being
a woman and
it's not it's not normal to
be completely wiped out and not be able
to go to your job or your kid's soccer
game or you know what i mean
just because you have your period
um so they're finding that it's a lot
more common
than it they thought it was
and
they say one in ten
wow
so now you go to atlanta to this
specialist
and what happens there
so
dr alby
he
um
this one i don't remember too much i
think because i was on pain meds and
when i say pain meds i mean
extended release morphine sulfate
um pills
i was like in a daze
yeah you know
especially at 13 14 years old
but that's that's how bad my situation
was you know so i don't really remember
too much myself of that surgery but
i do know that he told me
my mom has a tape actually it's kind of
cool to listen to where he sat down with
my family after the surgery and told him
everything that he found what he did
and his biggest thing was preserving
fertility like we're going to make sure
that she can have children if she
chooses to that's awesome
i mean it's really awesome that
someone's like look you know we're going
to try to preserve that instead of just
saying look [ __ ] it that's not going to
happen for you but we're going to make
sure you're healthy
yeah do you know at this point if you
can have kids
well i had a hysterectomy um
yeah
but it was kind of like
i mean i just got to the point where i
was so sick
that uh
i didn't care
so yeah i'll bet
now
i kind of i deal with a lot you know
like
well i should have at least tried but
i was told dr alby said
if i got pregnant in my left uterus that
i would most likely miscarry and he was
saying like women with this condition
can have up to six or seven miscarriages
before they carry full term
and i was like that's a no for me
yeah
like absolutely not i knew i couldn't
survive that so i kind of from age
about age 17 when things just like kept
going i was like it's not happening for
me it's not for me so take me back to 15
where you say you had more things that
were discovered or or
you know just kept going for you
i know
i mean who the [ __ ] was your primary
care physician
every year there's some new [ __ ]
i've had i've blown through a lot
because
they get exhausted and they're like i
like i've had a few
finally just throw their hands up and
like i don't know what to tell you dude
i don't know what to do
but
[Music]
yeah i uh
had started having back pain like in my
sternum
and uh like nerve pain down my legs and
then my legs just started oh another
[ __ ] uterus is growing yep yep
like this is it there's there's more
uh but
i i honestly think now looking back
there might have been some endometriosis
wrapped around my nerves
i still think i have that because if you
don't remove it
it just it doesn't go away
there's no treatment to dissolve it or
you know
there's no special i mean you can eat do
diets and stuff for an anti-inflammatory
to stop it from growing but you can't
just make it disappear uh
like a tumor you know
so
yeah my
my legs i would get out of the shower my
legs would be bright purple
and
numb and i'm my mom's like
what the [ __ ] like what is going on with
you
uh should we go to a cardiologist find
out i have
a duplicated
inferior vena cava uh ivc
why do you have a double of everything
everyone's like you were supposed to be
a twin right because like i have some
extra floating ribs that's interesting
do you really
i'm double jointed in some spots yeah
it's
weird but it's all cell split when
you're in you know the gestational
period of that time
and a lot of these
issues all go hand in hand
all at the same time
so now what is the
solution to help you through this new
wave of [ __ ] and by the way are you your
mom's only child
oh no
i have two sisters
a younger brother and a step sister too
which i'm so close with her she's like
i don't even think step step sister
she's my sister uh but
i'm really close to my siblings they've
all they've always been very helpful and
supportive and has anyone else in the
family had anything like this or just
you
unfortunately uh well like my
grandmother and my mother both had
problems with their uterus with
adenomyosis
which is basically
endometriosis grows into the tissue of
your uterus it's very painful
but the only way to diagnose it is
through hysterectomy so it's very
unfortunate for women that have that um
i thankfully didn't have that i
probably want to notice the difference
because i was in so much pain
but my two of my blood sisters they both
have endometriosis and have had
surgeries and
my oldest sister actually had
a seven year battle with infertility
because of endometriosis and pco
polycystic ovaries and
all that fun stuff
so
tell me what you were diagnosed with at
age 16. i mean we're just going year by
year here this is nuts
so when i was 16
16 17 see like it's kind of a blur
sometimes because i've seen too many
specialists when i was diagnosed with
what but
that was when i started having like skin
rashes and i was having joint pain and
i was having blood work that was like
off the charts
irregular
um
so then i was sent to an
autoimmune doctor which is a
rheumatologist
and
my sister at the time was just diagnosed
with systemic lupus and it was the same
doctor so i that i went to what is that
so
so lupus is um an autoimmune disease and
it is when you're basically your immune
system attacks healthy tissue like so
like when you get sick or you have a
bacteria in your body your immune system
amps up and goes after it to get rid of
it
with this though your immune system gets
like confused
and starts to attack your joints it can
attack your skin like there's different
kinds of lupus there's discoid which is
skin
um there's a blood lupus and
i think there's like four different
kinds but of course
systemic lupus is
it attacks everything pretty much
uh your organs your skin your blood your
joints
now you have this as well
you find out at 16 you also have it
well as of late uh my rheumatologist now
is wondering if it's more of like a
mixed connective tissue disease
or they say
undifferentiated connective tissue
disease because they there's something
causing your immune system to attack
your tissues and your joints and
your connective tissue you know uh
like organs and
and uh
he
he doesn't like to put that label on it
because with lupus a lot of times it can
cause serious issues with the kidneys
and
i have had problems with my kidney but
not like what's called lupus nephritis
which is where your lupus literally
attacks your kidneys and puts you into
kidney failure you have one
yeah
that's the only thing you didn't get
double up the damn kidney
stitch you needed
he could take his other uterus and his
other vagina and i'll trade it in for a
kidney goddamn it right can i just swap
it out
okay so now at 17 well you you said that
already we did uh lupus and but there's
more
there's fibroids oh yeah the stomach
fibromyalgia and then the stomach issues
like ibs
i mean i was just a mess like i just had
so many symptoms that we didn't know
which doctor to report it to you know
yeah and how many days are you missing
of school are they being supportive
through this like what's are you failing
what's happening
so like
seventh grade was when i first got sick
eighth grade was when i had my first
surgery
they were great
um in middle school high school not so
much like they're like we're prepping
you for life you know you gotta make
sure you get your credits and
all that [ __ ] but
um
my mom had to fight them a lot
um especially with things like
you know how like
teachers will tell you can't go to the
bathroom
i had a field day with that i mean i'd
be like
i
need to go bathroom and my male teacher
would be like
you got to wait until we're done with
this work she did and i'd stand up and
be like sir i need to change my tampon i
have two uteruses
i am bleeding
like a cut up
i'm like taking an animal
yeah
like i
embarrassed a lot of men in high school
but
including
punk asses i mean they used to call me
dp
double [ __ ]
see i'm thinking double penetration
because you have to but it's
double [ __ ]
now like that's not even like what it is
bro like get educated you know
but
i know dude
and that's the thing like people are
like i can't believe like you joke about
it like that and i'm like if i didn't
like i would not survive it like i have
to laugh
but uh
yeah i uh
this is a good one i
did half days uh part of
my sophomore year and junior year
and um
because my parents worked no one could
take me home halfway through the day
so i got to ride the short bus home
just me on the short bus by yourself
nobody else on
nope right in front of my house
um
my family will never
let me live that down i don't believe i
would too
i get a random hey jess what flavor was
your window today like
just
off the wall [ __ ] still
10 years later
but
that's what you got to do you got to
like power through it
and a lot of kids that were [ __ ] to
me i just
you know told the [ __ ] off made a joke
about it
and
on to the next one
wow plow through it
you i mean so far you are plowing
through this [ __ ] and now at 18 what
happens
yeah so this has actually evolved since
i sent that submission so um
of course like i've had a talk therapist
same one since i was 13. she's amazing
um she's actually like the family
therapist okay good that's what i was
gonna ask you if you
if you had to go on to talk to somebody
i hope so absolutely that was one of the
first things my mom did
because uh
my sister
suffered from depression and stuff like
that so she saw this therapist she's
like okay you need to get into this lady
still seeing her to this day
but um
yeah i uh i mean clearly i'm gonna be
depressed you know from all that and
isolated i mean i was missing everything
with school
and
when i got out of school all my friends
went to college
um
some just got into heroin which i wasn't
gonna do that either you know so i was
just like well good though because you
could have slipped into it you'd already
been taking painkillers so easy else you
could have just gone the other way and
been a junkie and died
i honestly don't
i think being sick was the only
thing that
stopped me from trying it
to be completely honest um
i mean my whole tight-knit group of
friends got into at one point or another
i have a best friend my best friend liz
from that i grew up with that was like
my rock through all my health stuff um
she overdosed
passed away
2018
i think it was
2017. i have a little
memorabilia for her
but um i've lost probably
a dozen
friends to heroin fentanyl what else
yeah i know that's all so no joke right
now dude and that's what that's what
happened with liz yeah
i watch all and i'm from baltimore i
watch all that [ __ ] and they're talking
oh yeah these guys are cutting it and
throwing it right in the pills and i'm
watching the the [ __ ] agents maryland
maryland's awful yeah and they're
touching they're touching it and
overdosing the the got the agents that's
how strong this [ __ ] is and then they're
putting yeah cutting it into the it's
was it a thousand times stronger than
heroin yeah it's
it's dead it's literally it can go
through your skin yeah it's your skin
and um it's funny because one not really
funny but one of my surgeries
i woke up from they told me they gave me
fentanyl
and with the nerve block and i was
pissed because i was like
i have like friends that have died from
this i don't
want this in my system i don't want to
touch this i don't even need
even if it's from the doctor i don't
want this
you know because i've just lost so many
friends to it but
it's wild man pennsylvania ohio
but yeah so i i was on like you know
bike it in and perk sets
in high school and
you know my friends are
starting to smoke weed and
pop pills and i'm like
why do you do that for fun because like
my mom has to fight me to take my
morphine you know what i mean because i
hated the way it made me feel made me so
sick and every time i got off of him i
withdrawed
like a [ __ ] you know so
i'm like why would you want to put
yourself through that i just never
understood it and i honestly i really do
think that's the only reason why
i'm not like them yeah just because i
was sick and scared
so can i ask you some personal questions
now
absolutely well i thought we were a
person i mean i'm going to ask you about
dating and stuff and and oh absolutely
what sort of anxiety you have when and
how old are you when you really first
starting to date how are you what age
are you comfortable to finally
get out there and experiment and stuff
yeah um
so around age 15 was about when all my
friends started
i definitely was one of the last uh
it was 16
when i finally did i believe
i don't know my mom's probably gonna
watch us you lost your virginity
yeah you did you might have been 15.
during all over 15. during all those
surgeries and
yeah because
so when i after my
surgery in atlanta they told me that i
need to suppress my period that would be
the best option for the endometriosis so
it doesn't grow back or continue to
spread
um so i was on all kinds of different
birth controls and then i was at finally
put on a drug it was like called depo
shot um and it's still used today not as
much i don't think um but it's used for
regular birth control and that's the one
for like last for like a few months or
something like that three months usually
yeah but i was getting them once a month
because i had because well i have double
everything i don't have double hormones
i
was even told once that i have double
sex glands which i believe it so
you know
but um
it really helped
like the vaginal pain
like i saw cramps and bloating and stuff
like that but
i didn't have that pressure and vaginal
pain like i used to so
you know all my friends were getting
into it so i was like i think it's time
to finally like
figure out you know if i am gonna have a
normal sex life
and the first time
completely normal
no pain
whatsoever
um now i don't know if that's because i
was on the depo shot because that was
not the story for the rest of my
sexual life i mean
when i was in
i think i was a senior i had a i always
i usually had well in the beginning i
was a little
a little promiscuous because i was like
found out that i could use my vagina
like a regular woman so i was like hey
well you know
once a shot a dp but
[Laughter]
i usually was in like long-term
relationships i was uh you know locked
down and comfortable with who i was
sleeping with so
when things did get painful
i could be open and honest
and
some were okay with it some you know
like my boyfriend now he's
he's a saint he's like the most
understanding man i've ever met
um
some
weren't very good about it
and uh
or the infertility thing
like towards the end of high school when
i was getting more serious with
boyfriends
i was like you know i don't
really know if i'm gonna be able to have
my own kids and
for one
uh it was a big deal he's like
that's it but i want i need my to be
able to have my own children
and that's what
in the end that's why we split i mean he
was also cheating on me all the time so
it was really a blessing in disguise for
me
but
uh
it really mattered to some
but uh
yeah and where it was
so
now
how are you i gotta ask you 27 27. so
this is i mean
you're young still obviously so you've
been half your life has been going
through this [ __ ]
yep damn
so how is your life now like what's
going on with old dp now
[Laughter]
that's great
so uh yeah i met
my boyfriend josh
in 2011
and
we've been together since yeah
i mean
there's we've had wait nine years 27 so
what [ __ ]
19 yep i was 19 years old he was he's
five years older than me
he graduated with my sister so like i
knew his family already i knew i was
friends with his sister
and
um you know his mom worked with the
school so like i already knew his family
i didn't really know him
um but then when we started hanging out
you know it was just like perfect
because his family
already knew
about
most of my issues and i knew i wouldn't
have to have those awkward conversations
of like when he having kids and
you know stuff like that so that was
awesome but i mean i've put him through
hell like i mean this man
i don't understa he must really love the
dp because i don't know how he's
sticking her out
i mean now we're i mean we're great now
absolutely great we just bought a house
in uh january together finally we're
living at my mom's and
it was starting to get you know
affect our relationship too
um and my moods and you know so just
having our own space and um our own
garden and yeah make sure that radish
doesn't have two uteruses girl
it's funny because the one the one i
pulled out earlier had two
[Laughter]
so i want to ask you
like i said it's it's only been what
10 13 half your life are you
do you still periodically like monthly
have to go get checkups i'm still
figuring it out um
right now
i work a lot with my rheumatologist he's
my biggest
helper i guess you could say
and i see two gynecologists
two different ones one for
uh you know pelvic floor well i have
pelvic floor dysfunction so i have
spasms and stuff like that so she like
prescribes me valium and
we talk about like pelvic floor therapy
and [ __ ] like that
the other one is the surgeon that did my
endometriosis surgery last
um
i've had like four different surgeons
with these surgeries
been around the block with those
but um i keep up what i just wrote this
down actually earlier you know
how many times you've actually been out
for surgery put under
oh put under you know that's a whole
nother story homeboy being cut open is
seven
i've had awake for some of those or
twilight for some of those
all those i was out
totally up
i've had um because of my interstitial
cystitis and my bladder i've had what's
called hydrodistension where they knock
you out cold
and fill your bladder up and stretch it
because a lot of times with ice
well they do it as a diagnostic
tool as well because they blow it up and
then they see if you have the little
tears in your bladder wall
so they also can stretch it and it helps
you know with ic go to you pee
constantly like some go like 30
40 times a day because they their
urgency is so bad so your bladder is
trained it gets
smaller and smaller but i've had
probably six of those over the years
i've had three colonoscopies
um
those are the only ones that really they
put me under
but i've been through a lot of
procedures traumatic yeah awake
procedures what's the most traumatic
awake procedure
what do you remember hearing feeling
i would have to say
for me at least
uh remember earlier we talked about the
cervixes how they were like this
so i had an abnormal pap smear come back
so when you have that what they do is
called a copolscopy
i think that's what it is
yeah so it's a scope basically to just
look really closely at your cervix cells
um and they like put this like vinegar
substance on your cervix to light it up
the cells and it'll show them where the
abnormal cells are and they'll biopsy
those spots
well the left because that's the side
that was pushed with the septum
it was like digging for gold to try and
find the cervix
like the whole other side of it because
it was like tucked up behind so they
would have to like
get in there and then they're like i'm
so sorry and says i'm like and just you
have no idea
oh like to pull it yeah out to
get access to it to
yeah
so that i sweat
crowbar so bad
oh my god oh my god i have never sweat
so bad on a table and then they take a
little snip
of your tissue to biopsy it
and uh if it comes back you know i have
pre-cancer cells that was another thing
with that pushed me into the
hysterectomy is i have pre-cancer cells
they don't know if i probably had hpv at
some point um because you can
test positive or not test positive for
it and still have had it at some point
in your life
um it's just your body rid of the virus
which is weird because you would think
with my immune system
it wouldn't but maybe that's why i had
the cancer cells uh so
that pushed me into getting the
hysterectomy as well was those cells
but that was definitely probably one of
the worst i was awake for man you're
strong as [ __ ] girl
i try man i don't have a choice like
it's like what are you gonna do are you
gonna
go to the doctor do the test take care
of yourself
or are you going to stay home ignore
what you need to do not take your meds
and what die possibly like
it's just a part of the survival and
like now
um i'm very fortunate to have a job
where i could work from home not just
because of the
coronavirus but
i went home like a week before the
shutdown happened
um
so like i've been looking for something
like this
since high school you know
like you're right i'm like
yeah i've been wanting to work from home
for so long because
there's just some days i don't want to
fake it like i'm pretty and this is the
thing this is the
problem with it
you put makeup on you smile you joke you
laugh you look good and then people are
like
but you have all these problems like you
don't look sick
well that's not going to show on the
outside of my body yeah tell my two
[ __ ]
yeah you [ __ ] want a hand coming on
my forehead like i don't understand
what you think this is
uh so
but
since it happened so young and it's been
going on for so long i've just learned
to just
you got to be cheerful
and
push through it or it's gonna like why
be miserable if you can be
as positive as possible and as happy as
possible so i just try to keep that
you know
motivation going but some days i'm like
[ __ ] this
well i really appreciate you coming on
here today with me and and being my
first female guest
i got to say that that's right thank you
gene yep gene
and uh thank you jess for real i really
appreciate you coming on you're great
thank you for opening up and sharing
your story with all of us
yeah of course thank you so much for
having me i really wanted i've been
wanting to do this for years just to put
out there that
people like me like you're not alone
dude and
having a painful vagina is not normal
and
you need to go to the doctor and take
care of it
but yeah
all right well thank you so much
thank you and thank you guys to make
sure you tune in every week and if you
know somebody you think would be good or
if you think you'd be good send in your
story to honeydewpodcast gmail.com we'll
get to them and hopefully we'll get you
on talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
you